des sapins des couronnes et même les
rennes du père noël le château de
villandry aussi cède à la frénésie des
fêtes
et pendant que les enfants sont captivés
par des histoires derrière les plus
grands s'émerveillent devant cette forêt
enchantée et ses animaux j'adore en fait
tout ce qui est décoration art floral et
c'est donc je me régale beaucoup je
connaissais le château j'étais venu une
fois c'est vrai que ça le transforme
complètement et il ya des compositions
magnifiques
je trouve que ça le rend vivant voilà
les châteaux des fois c'est un peu des
pierres et bon déjà là et les chouettes
mais ça le rend vivant on a l'impression
qu'il ya une famille qui va passer noël
là et non ça ça rend vivant le château
dans chaque pièce
la décoration est conçu pour s'intégrer
dans le décor existant dans ce salon
oriental une crèche orientale évidemment
avec mes grands parents on fêtait noël
ici et j'ai tout à fait souvenir de
crèches comme installer ici est un peu
plus peut-être peut-être mais similaire
à celle que alors l'accord entre gentils
l'esprit du lieu est aussi conserver
villandry est un château familial alors
dans le salon principal henri carvallo a
fait installer une crèche géante au même
endroit que celle des noëls qu'il
passait ici durant son enfance
c'est une crèche avec des éléments qui
évoque un peu le pays de naissance de
jésus voyait notamment fait jamais au
relais les habits des des participants
un peu comme on verrait sur un tableau
représentant la nativité derrière la
magie de noël un objectif pour villandry
booster le nombre d'entrées en saison
hivernale
les visiteurs ont jusqu'au 12 janvier
pour venir admirer les décorations
[Musique]